hey everybody just wanted to say thank
you for
uh following me social media star adam
perkins has died
he was 24 years old on tuesday adam's
twin brother patrick confirmed on
instagram that he died on sunday writing
i can't even really put into words what
this loss means for me
i'm often asked the question what's it
like to be a twin and my response is
usually
what's it like to not be a twin hello
my name is edward i'm spencer and
we are making this video today because
our father
who we love very much and who by the way
owns
half of manhattan is amazing
patrick goes on to write being a twin is
a very central part
of my identity it's all i've known and
i'm struggling to find the words to
explain what it will be like for me to
live in this world without him
my best friend the cause of death has
not been revealed
adam first became a social media
sensation on the now defunct platform
vine you know i'd call myself a consumer
but then again who isn't these days
he first garnered attention with his
iconic welcome to chili's video in 2015.
hi welcome to chili's not only did the
clip go viral but it had over 20 million
loops in one year spawning multiple
remixes
and the popularity of the video has not
gone unnoticed
especially since adam joined tick tock
last year back in like
2015 or around then i made this video
called hi welcome to chili's and i put
it on vine
and i recently saw this
i just really want to say i'm i'm kind
of i'm sorry
aside from his presence on social media
adam also had his heart set on music
graduating from nyu with a degree in
musical composition in 2018.
that same year he released his first
album latch relay
under the name plasteg adam's
ex-boyfriend kelton elliott acknowledged
his musical talents in a touching
tribute on instagram
writing me and him discussed how we'd
want to be remembered after we died
he said he'd like to be remembered for
his art his music
kelton also encouraged fans to listen to
the album on spotify
specifically his favorite song redwood
reverie
[Music]
you